yeah thanks so much and thanks so much
for having me
I will talk about
um the why and the how
of taking open source for us to a safety
certified robotic software framework and
at the end also a bit about our
experience what worked what didn't the
challenges we encountered
a little bit of History first
um as pointed out I started my PhD work
in in autonomous driving in the late 90s
built up completely driving this week
today we would call it a level 4 vehicle
one of the challenges we faced back then
cars didn't have any actuators any any
electronical interfaces uh to actuate
the vehicle with so we first had to
build this robot to sit on the driver's
seat based on a robot for emission tests
so robot with three legs with three
pedals uh an actuator for the steering
wheel later on we added more actuators
for the levers behind the steering wheel
actually worked beautifully about the
end at the robot alone was more
expensive than what the customer wanted
to pay for the whole system in addition
we had to work with
um
very early stage lidar so the blue boxes
on the on the front were lighters we
took from Industrial Automation camera
pre-production radar so really
everything was pre-production that
started two years before the first
driver assistant systems they hit cars
as a product
then I spent a couple of years
prototyping what we at the time called
Advanced Driver assistance so on the
left you see we call it traffic jam
assist it's essentially a level two
system very similar to what autopilot
has today and on the right we prototyped
a left turn assist prevents you from
making unintended left turns into
oncoming traffic
prototype here
was done around
2004-2005 and then it took another 12
years to make it into a product and that
already tells you a bit about the speed
of adoption of innovation in the
automotive industry
late 2006 I moved here to Stanford I'm
here in the bottom right of the picture
to work at Sebastian's lab for a couple
of years during the double Urban
challenge
since 2010 I teach mb3 2B and then
around 2009 I got involved with this
little garage Willow garage a company
here in Menlo Park
started by Scott Hassan one of the
earliest Google employees who wanted to
make progress in robotics and then he
found uh it's very interdisciplinary
there's not a lot of collaboration going
on between software Hardware
electronics and so on so he then took a
project here from Stanford Candace here
great to see you again the pr1 and they
they rebuild it to make the PR2
the PR2 was in a very uh capable I
believe 27 degree of Freedom robot which
could get your drink could play pool and
then another project was taken here from
Stanford which was switch yard at the
time which Morgan wrote I believe in
Andrew Ink's lab and that then became
Ross the Robot Operating System
which was a really the first capable
omnipresent widely spread robotic
software framework
then Villa garage built 20 of these
robots gave 11 away for free and for
free under the condition that every
single recipients would do with it had
to go back into Russian that's really
how Roscoe jump started 10 went to
universities including Stanford here and
one went to a corporate lab and that was
my lab at Bosch and right on the gray
shirt here in this image now fast
forward 12 years Ross is really
omnipresent not just in Academia but
also in the industry widely adopted for
prototyping you can see pretty much
every major autoplay Automotive player
uses it but then
ultimately we found everybody gets stuck
taking the prototypes which is greatly
accelerated into a product
I was then at Bosch at the time we were
the first company to support Ross then
did a lot of Robotics project with with
it uh teaching robots how to cook
teaching robots how to deliver mail use
power tools for t-shirts then we started
to use it for product development we
used it heavily for the development of
software for the robotic lawnmower ended
up not being able to fit it onto the
embedded system whereas one was simply
too heavy and the the embedded
microcontroller was simply too small
then we spun it out we spun out a
company called Mayfield robotics to
develop consumer robots that company
then shut down a couple of years later
pretty much as all the robotics toy
companies in the space then we took Ross
into Agriculture and then we also took
Ross into autonomous driving and rewrote
the Stanford software we used during the
urban challenge to run on Ross and that
was the first vehicle
which which ran that software and then
we built up another one built based on a
Tesla platform then I left Bosch joined
a car maker for the future we again used
for us for prototyping we again got
stuck taking Ross into into product
and that's a let's see to the idea of
starting a company started Apex aisle
over five years ago and in a nutshell
what we do is we have taken Ross
Ross who actually at the time which came
out end of 2017 early 2018 and we
always rewrote it from scratch based on
the same architecture and then spent
about a year certifying it to the
highest level of Automotive functional
safety and that's that process I will
talk about today
uh
just very brief background on the
company via Venture funded obviously
here
various Center Road investors light
speed Canaan invested and then fairly
early on the automotive industry we came
interested and we have by now 10
strategic investors as you can see here
car makers and and tier ones and also
agricultural companies
companies now over 100 people we are
present in eight countries with five
offices and four entities
and that now brings me to the topic how
we took open source uh into an
automotive product
and when when starting the company you
look back roughly on on 20 years of
robotic software development and what I
noticed is the first 10 years of my
career
there was no reuse basically for every
project we rewrote everything from
scratch as you can as you can see
project lasted at least three four years
all of a sudden Ross came out and we
were able to to prototype applications
in a couple of days to a couple of weeks
so the process of prototyping was
was
greatly accelerated and that really
taught me the power of a software
platform and what we are now doing is
taking that from a prototyping platform
into a product platform
another way of looking at it
um the first 10 years of my career
basically we redeveloped every idea
three times for proof of concept a
prototype and then a product each of
those steps in automotive takes at least
three years sometimes four and then you
end up with Innovation Cycles from ideas
to product of Way Beyond 12 years
for for simple simple functionalities at
the time and then it's really not a
surprise that developing a robo taxi or
a much more complex application in a in
a highly safety regulated domain like
Automotive takes more than a couple of
years
with Ross really the first stage of that
process was accelerated with ros2 which
came out again end of 2017 early 2018
also the prototyping stage because it's
closer to real time more reliable got
accelerated but still taking it into
product
more or less all companies deviated from
Ross and either did their own thing or
rewrote it and what we have now
developed is
one one system that can take that you
can take from POC over project to
product
in in that regard the automotive
industry today is really where the
smartphone the IT industry was about 15
years ago
20 years ago I had one of these Nokia
phones and just had arrived here at
Stanford 2007 the first iPhone came out
and that's exactly where the automotive
industry is today taking cars from a
hardware Centric device to a software
defined device where you can add
functionality also during the lifetime
and the ad software and add
functionality by adding software you buy
a car today
functionality over the lifetime
typically does not change yes maybe you
can you can download a a more up-to-date
map but that's pretty much it today
and really the the enabling Factor was
not the device that wasn't the App Store
it was a software development kit which
sits in between the base software of the
device and the application and it
abstracts all the embedded Hardware on
the device which really isn't that much
different from the embedded Hardware on
a card today
and makes it so simple that every
student also high school or middle
school student can essentially develop
complex software for complex embedded
device
so what we are focusing on
is ultimately enabling deterministic
real-time performance on a very resource
constraint embedded system
such that
large
software development teams can work
efficiently and be productive and by
large
the software software development teams
at a karmic or tier one they arrange
everywhere from a couple of dozen people
to a couple of hundred or a couple of
thousand people and most of them are
not experts for programming embedded
systems they're experts for perception
planning
and really really expert on the
application Level but not experts on the
embedded programming real-time creating
deterministic software level
so we then looked at
[Music]
um
to understand what we needed to do in
order to make Ross or us to
a capable proprietary
real-time deterministic software package
we found a couple of things
we needed to change the memory
allocation threading remove all the
blocking calls
so for instance in in Rust 2 you you
read and send the data from a lighter
from camera ros2 allocates memory
um
on subscription of a topic on
subscription of a memory that's highly
Dynamic it's great for prototyping
because it enables you to prototype
quickly but it prevents you from
creating ultimately a deterministic
real-time system
so what we ended up doing is we ended up
rewriting
all the memory operations
in Ross and the underlying libraries
that pertains to all the standard
Library containers which you typically
use through the whole sdl Library
um but then also we need we we noticed
we needed to deal with exceptions I'll
come to that in a bit then the whole
data transports so getting data from
um one process to another process or in
case of a car you have anywhere between
a couple of dozen and a couple of
hundred so-called ECU so computers
spread around the vehicle so you need to
get data from let's say the radar sensor
to the computer processing the radar
data so that's the the whole data
transport
and then we tackle the whole topic topic
of threading where uh in Ross and in any
any research software really you can't
um control sufficiently uh threading
priorities scheduling CPU pinning so
assigning tasks with certain core for
instance you use blocking calls blocking
calls are writing to disk or writing to
the network interface if your disk is
full you don't want your car on the
highway to order stop reacting
um so uh can't developers blocking
course can work with Deadlocks and
um as I said an embedded computer on a
car is very resource constrained you
want to run very complex algorithms on
it so you need to
ultimately make the application as as
efficient as possible and such that a
again a non-uh embedded software
developer can actually do that reliably
so if we ended up
removing all the dynamic memory
allocation from Ross in the underlying
libraries that also entailed writing our
own containers also such that they run
on
on x86 and arm architectures such as and
such that the application on top doesn't
need to change when you move from one
architecture to another
um we ended up not changing or finding a
solution for
um for working with exceptions but we
made the process of catching exceptions
deterministic and that ended up being
sufficient we completely rewrote
the data transport for automotive that I
will come to that in the second half
of the talk and we ended up writing our
own threading libraries and put a large
emphasis on
execution management such that the
application developer so again Someone
Who develops perception software or or
planning software does not need to deal
with
dealing with mighty mighty threading for
instance on on different Target
platforms
so we rewrote our own memory allocators
we rewrote our own shredding libraries
and I wanted to give you a couple of
examples how that then pertains to
somebody working on perception over
somebody working on planning
oh
um so what is an Executor an Executor is
is a piece of software that sits in
between the task so the task could be
again reading and Center data and
working on for instance fusing camera
and lighter data
and then configures the thread so how
thread runs threads run on a
on a multi-straded system
in ros1 which is the original version of
Ros that is essentially a piece of
software that takes events so events
could be your camera sends you in a
camera image or your lighter sensor
sends you a new lighter frame
and then start the thread so a threat
then contains whatever you want to
process the algorithm you wrote
that is simple and works well for
something simple like a user interface
where you press a button and then up and
pressing the button you want to execute
a certain function like
turn read the news or or turn on the
radio
but the typical robotics use case is for
instance data Fusion taking data from
camera so camera image and taking data
from the radar so radar frame and then
fusing it
so one way to do it is you you wait for
for the trigger on a radar message for
instance and then you read in the most
recent
camera image and some transformation
that transforms for instance the
coordinate system of your camera to the
one of the radar or the other way around
but then you have to deal with a
different
um
different cycle times of the radar
different cycle times of
um of the camera and that ultimately
generates a lot of overhead and so why
should the application developer deal
deal with callbacks for messages that
you don't need for instance here
um you have a camera image that you're
not using because you're you're waiting
for the radar to trigger the processing
um
why should you deal with as an
application developer caching messages
until you have one that you actually
want to use so that should all be
abstracted from
um from the application developer
so really the way you want to do it is
you want to trigger you want to have a
certain triggering topic so in this very
simple example that that would be a
radar message and then
the system in this case the the executor
provides you whatever you need in terms
of data so the most recent radar message
and the most recent camera image for
instance
but then you have other use cases like
planner execution so you don't want to
run up on getting the latest radar
message but you want to run exactly
every 10 or 100 milliseconds so then you
need
um
you need an Executor that can can be
triggered by time
so there is example here but then in
order to make that robust maybe you need
both
here the use case here would be you
really trigger on radar but let's say
the radar is down you don't want to wait
forever until you execute
um send the data processing so you you
would then trigger on radar but in
addition have a timeout
so let's say a 10 hour milliseconds so
you do some processing in in the in the
failure case where you haven't received
a radar message in a certain amount of
time but again imagine an um
and an engineering team of a couple of
hundred or a couple of thousand people
you don't want every team every sub team
to come up with their own solution for
this so really that needs to be
abstracted
by the software framework
and then there are more use cases like
um multiple execution conditions or you
don't want to execute just a single item
but have a directed graph of items that
could be could be linear or could also
be
um
be several execution items in parallel
that is all possible and that is
actually
um
with um
with an Executor like this and the
simple version or exists in ros2 we
contribute to that in open source and
then the the real-time certified version
that exists in in our software
so that is one example of
um of the additions we made we made to
Ross to Ross too
another big one is legal communication
so by weaker communication I mentioned
that earlier you have anywhere from a
couple of dozen to a couple of hundred
ecu's essentially embedded computers
around the vehicle and they're typically
separated into domains so one domain
would be the body that's the air
conditioning or the windows everything
that is entailed in the chassis then you
have the powertrain that is what drives
the vehicle a does is driver assistance
infotainment is the radio and the
telematics unit and the info and the and
the for instance the screens and then
telematics is essentially a cell phone
modem a fireball and a switch that
connects the vehicle to
um to the cloud
all these different domains typically
lose use different protocols in addition
the amount of data to be processed has
grown tremendously over the last 10 20
years in a 20-year-old car
basically a couple of messages in the in
the kilobyte range being sent around so
that the engine can talk
to the cluster instrument and and the
braking system for instance then drive
assistance came about 10 15 years ago
cameras were either added and now you
have vehicles with up to a dozen cameras
with anywhere from around 25 frames per
second in the megapixel range
um on a vehicle and that then quickly
gets you two gigabytes of data per
second so they have to now be piped
through the processing pipelines in
addition Vehicles today are connected
they're connected to the cloud they're
connected to infrastructure such as
traffic lights they are systems that
warn you of pedestrians crossing the
street for instance so that then adds um
it's the number of other protocols
also software architecture of the
vehicle is changing so pieces of
software gets moved get moved around in
the vehicle from one for instance from
one ECU to another and that really
shouldn't shouldn't um
have to change the application software
so what we ended up doing is writing a
piece of software also based on open
source that can deal with all those
different use cases but application
facing provides one API so the
application developer who doesn't really
have shouldn't really deal with what the
underlying bus and the underlying
protocol is
in practice that looks something like
this so the by now predominant bus in a
car is ethernet it's actually Automotive
ethernet but the effect to ethernet but
then there are
um there are also some some of the
microcontroller based ecu's typically
connected via can bus which is a very
simple Automotive bus
and then you have also more complex
computers here for instance an automated
driving domain controller which consists
of one or several socs connected by an
Ethernet switched and so in also
microcontroller units here
then the protocols
that either run on Ethernet or or then
run on Ken is on can obviously can but
on ethernet that can be some IP which is
an automotive protocol or DDS which is a
more modern robotics protocol which ros2
also uses but then there are also Cloud
protocols like mqtt
or if you want to watch a movie in the
car you need some video streaming
protocols
um but again ultimately the application
and that now goes back to ros2 to the
application it shouldn't really matter
which underlying which underlining Line
bus is being used so application wise
Ros uses so-called topics
topics are essentially a data Channel
and then you can publish And subscribe
data to that channel and
um
one or several subscribers can receive
data in one or several Publishers can
send data
actually fairly simple
in ros2 and most most applications
with
complex processing you you have a number
of different processes let's see here
you you have a lighter the lighter sense
data you read in the data you transform
it to some other coordinate system you
fuse it you filter ground you detect
clusters so objects and then you do a
collision estimation
using rust tool see just for sending the
data from one
process to another one that roughly
takes five milliseconds for substantial
amount of data the reason is it uses a
network stack
and the network stack then
requires to serialize the data it
entails copies
the larger the data grows so in case
it's a case of camera images that
results in a lot of copies and a lot of
data in a lot of data being copied and
then you end up
just for the messaging pipeline of
latency somewhere around 25 milliseconds
if you now take into account that the
car moves with several meters per second
that is actually a lot of time so the
car will have moved
just through
during the time which it takes to copy
to to serialize the serialize and copy
all the data
so
um
newer technology what what we have then
also added to ros2
is a so-called shared memory data
transport which is actually quite
logical but not the normal way Ross or
any other messaging robotic software
does it
um so you write data into a pre-educated
memory pool you write it you put it in
once and then the subscribers take it
out of the memory pool just by passing
pointers around and not by copying the
data anymore
and that then is obviously because
you're just passing pointers with a
fixed size
is um size agnostic
so you stay in the in the low
microsecond
range completely independent of the
message size whereas we ran that on the
real-time system for working with camera
the image size data you quickly get into
again the high millisecond latency
amount so that makes makes obviously a
huge difference
and that then brings me to to the last
topic which is safety certification
um automotive and other domains
in in which
operation can lead to damage or injuries
or deaths a highly safety regulated in
the automotive case that is governed by
a Norm called ISO 26262 for Machinery
it's typically IEC
61508 so their number of norms that
pertain both to system safety and then
to software safety and I don't believe
what they are is the collection of
safety goals so depending on the
criticality and the possible effect of a
safety critical failure
um
you do so-called safety safety analysis
and have that risk analysis and then you
derive then you come up with a certain
safety rating in automotive that ranges
from qm quality manage meaning you just
put in some quality measures to several
levels of
so-called safety levels and they are a b
c and d d being the strictest and
um
and the requirements for system safety
on the system level are roughly such
that for the highest level ACD there the
system prescribes there shouldn't be
more than 10 safety potentially safety
critical failures per 10 to the ninth
hours of operation so very few failures
in a very very large amount of time
also such that you cannot actually
typically not cannot show statistically
anymore that you've met the safety goal
so the way to then meet the safety goal
is really by applying all the safety
best practices that the norm recommends
and then in in Europe you actually have
a third-party company an assessor come
in and they then audit you and both the
company and the product whether you've
met that again for automotive that's ISO
and in this case the software package
is uh like like Ross in our case a
safety certified Ross has really been
developed
independent from the and actually before
the final application so when Ross was
developed Ross developers didn't know
how it would be used later on when we
certified we didn't know and we still
don't our future customers may be using
it so the norm calls that a safety
element out of context so a safety
relevant element which was developed
outside of the context of the final
application
and there's a specific process for this
in a nutshell
what we did is we first looked at every
rust package that we wanted to certify
and we reduce the the feature set so
obviously we don't want to certify stuff
that is in the end not needed then we
work through all the processes that I
mentioned earlier so elimination of
runtime memory allocations and blocking
calls for instance then we applied a
static coding analysis and you can you
can
both use open source tools or or by
proprietary tools so this is just up to
here it's really all standard
then
came the labor intensive part so that's
test tests and tests so for reaching ACD
the highest level you need to have
really a hundred percent test coverage
for all statements all branches and a
mcdc which is modified condition
decision coverage so you need to
make sure and show that for all possible
conditions in your software for instance
in a nested if statement you're really
running through all the conditions and
you've and you've tested all the
conditions
that is for complex software actually
not trivial
then you need to write requirements what
that means is
really
all the code you're writing is to have a
purpose the purpose needs to be clearly
defined and described
and tested and then you need to have
need to show need to generate and show
full traceability from each requirement
to which code does the requirement
uh which requirement is fulfilled by
which part of the code which code
fulfills which requirements so
bi-directional traceability and the same
for tests we need to show which tests
per tests uh which part of the code and
fulfills which requirement
then there are a number of specialized
tests then you need to do a so-called
failure mode analysis
um then for all the tools you're used
you either need to have a so-called tool
classification or you need to generate
one for instance for
um for the the coding tests the coding
guidelines the the mcdc tools and so on
and so on if you're using Excel
to manage your requirements you need to
qualify access
to use access for safety critical
application and so on and so on
then you need to look at a lot of
architectural metrics such as the
cyclomatic complexity which is really a
measure for how complex is the software
that you've written
then you need to document everything
including architecture diagrams to
control and data flow analysis then you
need to test all on all target platforms
so a Target platform is ultimately the
device
the customer for instance the car
company runs the software on so that
could be an Nvidia board a qualcom board
a TI board
and in our case then also the
combination of the actual kernels of the
real-time operating system on top and
that then quickly leads to
a fairly large number of of possible
Hardware platforms we are testing on
and then you need to generate so-called
safety artifacts safety artifacts are
really the safety planner safety manual
so that contains all all the assumptions
we've made in all the conditions under
which we've tested if then and that's
specific then also to a safety element
out of context so let's say
a customer
comes in two years and uses a software
on on a computer which we haven't used
during testing when we when we did the
certification then that's the violation
of the safety manual and then you have
to add those tests later on
um before the customer can obtain safety
certification for the final product
but the purpose of safety
certification as a safety element out of
context is really that you can save the
additional certification step later on
but if you as students later on ever
want to take a piece of software and
sell it into safety
critical application roughly these are
the steps
that you have to walk through
so for us
to give you some some estimate on some
effort estimation so
steps one two and three
for Ross two took us roughly two years
with a team of
at the time 30 40 persons and then
walking from working from four
to 13 was roughly another year with the
team by then
uh
40 40 plus persons
so roughly 40 percent years and maybe
100 years 60 200.
and then at the end
we got a certificate so really a one
piece piece of paper which shows safety
certification achieved
and then obviously software software is
never finished so their new software
versions we would then which we haven't
done since but we will eventually then
you need to do so-called data
certification so you need to look at the
difference what has changed and then
possibly recertify with your
certification partner
that then led to our first safety
certified
version of Ross which we then started to
roll out
into automotive and I'm not going to
spend the next 10-ish minutes to talk a
bit of about our experience doing that
so first a bit of a background so what
is what does an architecture Automotive
look like going back 20 years
the blocks here are either sensors or
ecus or computers it was really
very simple whatever needed to be
connected somewhere some of us connected
mostly the ecu's were running
independently and there was very little
networking going on so those are the
cars
roughly 20 years old
then the number of ECU started to grow
from from maybe a dozen to a couple of
dozens and then the first com party
mentalization into so-called domains
started so all the let's say AC
Computers window lifters
computers ecu's that control the lights
were grouped into a so-called body
uh domain then you have the chassis that
pertains to suspension and braking
powertrain and so on and then you
typically had more or less
three to four three to four more or less
independent networks in a car which will
Loosely connected whenever it was needed
so let's say your
your infotainment domain which drives
the cluster which is really the
instrument
needs to be connected to the powertrain
because the powertrain shows you the
RPMs of the of the engine and it needs
to be connected to the chassis because
there are wheel speed sensors which
measure how fast the vehicle goes but
Loosely really loose on demand
connection
then more recently so roughly around
five years ago the so-called Central
Gateway was added the Central Gateway is
really a cell phone more than the
firewall and a switch which then
connects the card to the internet for
instance to get you the latest map for
the for the navigation system
um or do some simple software updates
industry is currently in between the
third and the fourth generation of
vehicle architectures and then the
fourth generation ads so-called domain
controllers or domain computers these
are now for the first time
more powerful
microprocessor multi-core computers so
actually very similar to what is in my
iPhone for instance whereas all these
here are really single core
microcontroller driven fairly simple
devices
the reason is for the introduction here
uh current and future vehicle functions
require more more compute power so that
is for the info Entertainment System
rendering content on multiple screens to
driver assistance systems perform or
automated driving performing more more
complex functionality Tesla has domain
controllers in their vehicles for a
couple of years already
uh most other car makers
are in the process of introducing that
architecture in the next couple of years
possibly there will be a fifth
generation which then really where the
ideas you have one Central Computer in
the vehicle and all the all the devices
that are connected to it then run only
very little software typically just the
bus and the network interface
and then here you have uh really one
server grade powerful computer with
compartmentalization of domains done
virtually
for instance through virtual machines
and and hypervisors but the issue now
that that arose is
um
the automotive industry being automotive
industry introduced a new hardware
architecture
without really having a software
architecture that can that can support
the hardware architecture
McKinsey this is a graph I borrowed from
McKinsey uh roughly shows it like this
normalized here to 2008 so 15 years ago
McKenzie thinks that between then and
now the complexity of software has
roughly increased by a factor of three I
would argue it's actually significantly
more
and they also show that the productivity
in the automotive industry has increased
only a little whereas here the
productivity of the tech leaders
referring to Google Apple Facebook has
increased but by far not as much as a
complexity of software has increased
that's the message of
of the slide here the bad news is
McKinsey thinks that Gap will get get
even larger roughly by a factor of three
from today to 2030 I think it's going to
be significantly more
and the
um
the Practical result are actually
software bugs and in the in case of the
car industry delays of production
anywhere between also of rolling out a
car that is produced in Hardware where
the software either isn't working
properly or they can get it to work in
the first place by months two years
we've had several car makers
experiencing that
in the past few years and sometimes it
also makes it into the news for instance
in New York Times The Wall Street
Journal had a big article around
software delays and the billion dollar
damage it cost just a couple of uh
months ago
another interesting
um aspect of this slide here is this
Factor two between the automotive
software development productivity and
the tech leader software development
productivity so why is there a factor of
two
automotive and in robotics we are in a
safety relevant domain so safety is just
harder as I pointed that out earlier
there
um nine of the of the 13 steps really
pertain to safety
security is harder you don't want your
car or Rover to be hacked
the automotive industry is really
suffering by this Hardware first
approach so the automotive industry is
historically a hardware industry they're
not a software industry so I pointed
that out in the in the previous in in
the architectural slide automotive
industry introduces a hardware
architecture and then they notice hey
the software architecture the software
to support it is missing
it's also hard
for the automotive industry to get
software Architects so the ones that
really drive a new software because
Google Apple and Facebook suck them all
up
and it's not as sexy not as appealing
working on a car with Innovation Cycles
are many many years versus a consumer
device where you can see your your work
in a product in in the next few weeks or
months so that's just how it is in
addition
there are actually in C plus plus 17 C
plus plus 20 or rust for instance new
languages and new language features that
um head to abstract complexity and
software to a great extent
but they are hard to use for safety
critical applications so a substantial
amount of our time went into
reducing the feature set that we use and
then we allow our customers to use of C
plus plus to the functions that we
deemed appropriate for using in a safety
critical applications so there are a lot
of functionalities that can that reduce
the software complexity but
you can't really make them make them
being used in a safe way
and then for
um
for for the automotive industry making
Investments it's just hard in in a good
year car companies have a profit margin
of a couple of percent whereas in a good
year an internet company has a 10 times
higher profit margin so that's
um it's just hard to make make
investments but nevertheless all of the
complaining doesn't help productivity
needs to go up
then we started to
um to roll out the software to our
customers and we expected to encounter
something like this so four or five
domains body powered in Adas
um you then have have the respective
controller so let's take Adas in Ada's
ECU so multi-core
arm-based computer
with a base operating system so an rtos
that could for instance be q and x
um a middleware so the data transports
some software platform some apis maybe a
couple of suppliers that then deliver
the application software let's say for
for for parking parking AIDS or for
adaptive cruise control
and then you have the function software
in reality we encountered something like
this
a wired mix of
suppliers
um
inconsistent apis running on on one ECU
several implementations for instance of
data data transport software that more
or less does the same but really driven
by one or several suppliers here on top
they they then use all their stuff
then the next supplier has
the same the same
um
the same functionality implemented
differently than the OEM so the
manufacturer of the car wants to add
some functionality these are actually
not available as source code to the OEM
typically because the supplier keeps in
proprietary and then they do their own
implementation on top so more than once
we encountered the situation where
software for the same purpose was
running several times and being
implemented and they need to be cemented
several times on on one ECU so highly
highly inefficient and that then also
leads to the to the productivity Gap and
it leads to
to Resource issues on the device
so we've encountered several time
situations where
[Music]
um
a substantial model Computing resources
were eaten up by the base software not
leaving enough not leaving enough
resources for the function software
the solution
would actually be simple
having one operating system across the
whole device one data data transport
software the token middleware one
software framework one application API
and then all the all the functionalities
on top use that same API reality is
different and the reason is there is
just a lot of Legacy software in
automotive and on a car is a very
complex device and from one generation
to the next there's a lot of reuse you
can't redevelop realistically software
and functionality for whole car for each
generation from scratch and completely
based on new apis that's just how it
works another way to look at it is a
so-called recycle the V cycle is really
a model that shows how how cars or
complex mechatronical devices are
developed you basically start with
requirements requirements describing
what should the device do then you break
them down first input systems so system
could be the braking system the power
train the steering system and so on then
you break it down even further here than
the separation into mechanical systems
electrical systems Software System
starts at some point you reach down you
reach the component level
then and only then you start with the
actual implementation
once it's implemented you run up the
right half of the V again and then on
every layer you check
whether what you've implemented actually
matches what you've what with your
requirements were at some point you put
everything together and if you do that
in software and that's really up here
the system integration the vehicle
integration when you do that in software
when you do that in software with based
on on non-identical apis
so every domain using their own their
own apis and framework you don't run
through the vehicle cycle once but you
run through the V cycle
dozens or 100 times in parallel and the
resulting issue is
you notice you notice issues very late
let's say very simple case the message
one
super simple case the message One sensor
sends doesn't match to what what an ECU
expects so you need to change the
message parameter could actually be very
simple but since the OEM doesn't have
or the source code only the suppliers do
in the car today
you need to go back to the requirements
see what went wrong you need to run
through the whole V cycle again and that
sometimes takes a couple of months
and that then leads to a couple of
months for simple software update to do
one simple fix that's the and that then
contributes to the to the lack of
innovation speed in the automotive
industry today
if uh an enter and and a software-driven
company
would have all the software and source
code and can do a new software build
overnight
but that's not where car industry is
today at least not the not the
traditional car makers
But ultimately where the automotive
industry needs to get to is one software
layer one SDK for the whole car and most
of the car makers have actually realized
that some are getting that software from
us a lot are doing it in-house
um
but it's slowly but steadily settling in
that Carney makers need to need to move
from being Hardware Centric companies to
software-centric companies
um that brings me to the end
we've rolled it out in the meantime to
our software to to many domains not just
cars Rover taxis trucking companies
Marine boating companies so really any
robotic mechatronical system that where
you can use Ross for prototyping we in
the meantime have done projects in
with that I think we have about eight
minutes for questions I'll be happy to
take any questions you like
[Applause]
have you looked at fulfillment centers
like Amazon Walgreens and Walmart rather
um
we haven't so a lot of the uh but a lot
of the Fulfillment centers actually
so not Amazon for instance but a lot of
the robotics applications run Ross their
their way to
achieving safety is is often different
than in a car so those those robots
often run
s unmodified
really not being safe and not being
safety certified but they do achieve
system safety by running a so-called
supervisor which then often uses an
independent
sensor and indeed for often a lighter
and an independent safety rated computer
um to then simply detect
has the main system missed something
let's say an object all of a sudden pops
up in front of the front of the robot
and then the the whole robot is simply
being shut down so very similar to
Industrial robotics
um where you either have have it where
the robot is gated off or fenced off or
in the in the more modern system you
have a virtual fence based on the
lighter for instance where then
everything enters the safety safety zone
around the robot the robot is simply
shut down so that's typically how slower
moving robots in fulfillment centers a
real life safety
so thank you for your presentation
um my questions about I was struck by
the latency of some of the Legacy
protocols specifically the passing the
information between their different
processes well like the ethernet
especially the car ethernet protocol so
I guess the question I have is
um it's like is prior to actually
implementing a new type of
software architecture is that did it not
occur to anyone to actually upgrade uh
to move away from a tcip TCP IP stack to
something like a shared bus shared
memory like you're actually using today
or
I'm not it's just it seems like because
there were T speed IP it's great but
it's everyone's known for general for a
long time it's just you you stack on a
lot of layers and you have to take all
of them off in order to get back to the
data packet of course there's all this
overhead back and forth and errors and
memory if you're you know so anyway
there's a lot of stuff in TCP uh
ethernet so it's just kind of like it
wasn't an era or like car manufacturers
never had to contend with that before
now because we didn't have all this data
this all this information Fusion prior
to now and so yeah I'm just curious
about I mean it's so anyway good
Innovation that it's doing shared memory
and pointers much more efficient much
faster in rocket science it's really
Common Sense yeah exactly and it's just
curious like what it's there was no
Evolution between ethernet to that yeah
so so the reason is it really lies in
the uh traditionally the half the
Centric approach and Minds Council of
the industry so as I pointed out here
historically you really had one box per
function
with a single core
and the single and a single thread
running on a microcontroller
so one box with a radar I could have
actually brought one today where then
the whole functionality was implemented
on the microcontroller in the radar and
only more recently
namely pretty much where we are today
functionality is now moving from this
distributed system
into a into a system where you have
larger multi-core computers all of a
sudden
um
parallel processing and multi-threading
and yes up to now the
the software support that has been
missing
for those of you who are using Ross I
should have mentioned the the zero
software copy is also available as open
source and Ross in a project running
under the eclipse foundation called
Eclipse size RX in case anybody wants to
try it out
yeah I'm gonna ask some of the the
questions from the students on Zoom sure
has a question with regard to the
central data storage to decrease latency
with the increasing size of the data
transfer to tens of gigabytes per second
do you have to worry about the actual
distance between the sensor and the main
computer on on the robot also do you
need to work with a manufacturer to set
up multiple data lanes for redundancy
[Music]
um
to the first point to my knowledge no
distance is not an issue the car typical
car is fairly short
um so that is not an issue the second
one was pertained I believe to
redundancy
um so it's actually a common
misconception that that you do need
redundancy per se so what the
what the norm really prescribes
as a best practice to achieve safety is
um
it's the safety level you need to reach
and then you need to you typically do a
assist so-called system decomposition to
your breaker system down into all the
parts and then if all your components or
the failure cases of your components
alone cannot achieve
the safety goal that is required then
you start to work with redundancy so for
instance a radar has certain failure
cases the camera has certain failure
cases that are known and sometimes
they're unknown then you try to combine
both such that you have redundancy that
both do not fail do not show the same
failure case so in other words do not
fail at the same time but redundancy is
really a tool to to get to the safety
level and not a requirement
there's one over here
foreign
what they're doing today and I'm
wondering what's your thought on
Tesla situation with them being in a
different advantage of developing their
own software and what that leads through
their development time compared to other
vehicle infections so I showed the V
cycle earlier
um
a conventional car maker from the idea
and and starting with the requirements
of what a new uh what a new car should
look like let me just show you here
needs roughly from the requirements
level to the final integration testing
and then producing a vehicle and rolling
an out needs somewhere around five to
six years
Tesla does it in two and a half
does that answer your question
yes uh
I guess then my follow-up to that would
be
why isn't the industry
adopting like a uniform platform to
stock started on and build from that
um
if the car industry
if you develop if you'd invent the car
today
the car today then you would that's
exactly how you would do it you would
start with a with a platform approach
and I probably developed one cross
industry standard
and then
it's Android
15 years ago there was Windows Mobile
Blackberry had their own OS Nokia had
their own OS called Symbian and there
were a couple of others so you roughly
had around 10 10
um software
[Music]
smartphone or the previous smartphone
Area phone operating systems
today you have two
apple with iOS was first to market and
just arguably best in class and then
everybody dropped their own base
software
to adopt Android and now they are
competing on price
Hardware performance Hardware features
but not on the base software anymore so
customization happens through the
hardware
and differentiation and applications on
top
and that's really where where the car
industry should be
you won't notice the difference between
car a and car B
uh whether they're on a different base
software as long as it works doesn't
fail and allows you to update the
software on the car which by the way
nobody today can do besides Tesla and
maybe rivian and a couple of the other
new oems but they started or when they
introduced us software platform they at
the time built a couple of vehicles
the largest car makers in the world
Toyota and Volkswagen they built 10
million Vehicles a year
that's a vehicle every couple of seconds
and there's a lot of
Legacy and carryover both software and
Hardware
that actually works
in those Vehicles where it's just very
very hard to do everything from scratch
there is a new car makers they start
exactly like this they start with their
software platform they start with in
with electric vehicles with a so-called
skateboard platform where you really
have the whole electrical Powertrain
on one so-called skateboard but they
come from a completely different
starting point
they're not already at the point where
they're making 10 million Vehicles a
year or 1 million which is still which
has a smaller OEM which is which is
still a lot
sure can you hear me
yeah
um I really like your responsibilities
mm-hmm
my question
isn't a failure if that's even been
described the word of um
um I don't mean to be Emperor
so that's a longer answer let's have a
coffee at some point
yeah
um
you have the slide on centralization of
architecture doesn't that include
increase uh security vulnerabilities
uh that's number one and number two is
that uh
Microsoft and Amazon have made some
moves in Robot Operating Systems
how do you see the
the situation between closed versus open
software
so the first one was the centralization
of software and computers lead to uh
lead to larger leads to larger
vulnerability from a security
perspective
I would argue that it's easier to to
make one system safe than to make 100
computers in a car safe
so in any case the the vulnerability
typically
comes with the infotainment system
because that's what runs Consumer
Electronic codes for instance in the
Bluetooth deck in the Wi-Fi stack for
the USB connectors which you just have
to have to to connect your your consumer
device so you need to
usually through an onion principle that
just Shield those off but that's that
you have to do in any case what was your
second question
with respect to I'm not sure if I
understand how do you see do you see the
adoption more of the open source
software or oh okay and giving them
these vendors move at a much faster
product release right so in automotive
maybe the short answer is for automotive
infotainment by far most oems are we are
currently adopting Android automotive to
build the infosainment system stack
so there is a short answer and is that
open source more or less yes
boys thanks so much